foreign
depending on what games you play it's
either changed irrevocably or it never
changes at all myself I like to think
it's a little bit of both there are
moments of drastic Evolution but then
for what seems like an eternity it stays
exactly the same
[Music]
yes Doug sir have you seen the news
they've announced the new card Cod I'm
more of a ribs man myself they're
calling it the most advanced version yet
I don't care how advanced the card is
Doug you still can cover it in barbecue
sauce
what should we do same as ever collect
the facts remember we only know what
they want us to know our job is to look
between the cracks I'll be over soon
some folks adapt to change others like
our poor friend Doug there are terrified
by it myself I'm not against tradition I
like the comfort of A Familiar Taste as
much as anyone but when it comes to war
I'm hungry for something new
[Music]
foreign
what do we know so far it's new Call of
Duty Advanced Warfare Future Weapons new
geopolitical landscape pmcs that sort of
thing Who's involved it's being headed
up by Sledgehammer Games they picked up
the pieces on MW3 after that ugliness
with simpellan West
also Kevin Spacey's in it he tweeted
that he was excited oh I'm sure he is
Next Gen Korean gen whole new engine you
play as a single character for the
entire game private Mitchell Troy Baker
is doing the voice work Baker he played
Joel In The Last of Us and Booker and
BioShock Infinite he's a composed by
Harry Gregson Williams he worked on
Metal Gear Solid mgs2 through the
phantom pain the last call he worked on
was the first modern warfare and who is
that
oh I just love Nabi Navi the way
what do you think I think this pie has
got a lot of fingers in it so how about
we start with the head chef I believe
that's you Mr Schofield Glenn a Scofield
trained in both fine arts and business
he owned a BFA from the Pratt Institute
and an MBA from Golden Gate University
after a number of years cutting his
teeth as an artist he became vice
president Crystal Dynamics there he
headed up development on gex and Legacy
of Kane eventually moving to EA Redwood
Studios as general manager of the
company's visceral games that he created
his magnum opus through a collaboration
with one Michael condry hi I'm Michael
Condrey dead space a new IP went on to
be the most successful new properties of
the Year responsible for two sequels
Comics films novels and scaring the
living [__] out of grown men in there on
the way oh this video game is so gosh
darn scary I love playing it on my Sony
PlayStation 3. you know when I'm not
enjoying my PS4 my PlayStation Vita
greatness awaits baby
just to be clear that is a reference to
Sony product placement in House of Cards
not an admission of games press
corruption on my part believe me if my
voice was for sale it will be to the
highest bidder and right now that's
Nintendo oh and for the record I hated
Kanan Lynch
anyway need to be a Schofield and cold
were working on something else before
they were asked to finish Modern Warfare
3 a third person shooter set in a secret
conflict during the Vietnam war seems
they told our friends a Game Informer
that did a 15-minute demo before the
team was moved onto MW3 a demo that was
and I quote going for some Dead Space
moments
that's the thing that keeps bugging me
about this Activision are no strangers
to Acquisitions and mergers but their
track record isn't great we have a
saying down in Gaffney just because
you've got prized chickens doesn't mean
the farmer can still spoil the eggs yeah
wait what on one hand you have blizzard
when Activision merged with vivendi
blizzard retained autonomy regardless of
whether or not you're happy with their
releases since they're free to operate
as they please but then Activision of a
track record for working successful
franchises into early Graves Guitar Hero
Tony Hawk Pro Skater Call of Duty could
well be on the way to joining that
illustrious group in fact there are many
gamers who would love nothing more than
to witness this series Wilt and die but
then there are external pressures too
earlier this year respawn entertainment
made up of many of the boys and girls
who left during the development on MW3
released their first video game
Titanfall he was critically acclaimed
and sold rather well there's a good
chance that when we see a sequel it will
be multi-platform and respawns Second
Battle of the first person Cherry Matt
just draw blood while on the European
front Das and EA are still trying to
invade Cod territory with their
Battlefield series they just have to
release a game that actually works I
think I see what you're saying the Call
of Duty franchise stands in the end of a
precipice all that's left to do now is
Jump leave the pass behind you just have
the hope that they grow wings before
they hit the ground
what next we wait let's see let's go
feeling Co come up with we'll return to
this later
thank you Doug
so
Sledgehammer Games this is quite the
cross you've chosen to carry one of the
most beloved critiqued and hated
franchises in the history of video games
but what a Twist in the tale it would be
if the franchise that so many wanted to
die was what breathed new laugh into FPS
military shooters
so
Sledgehammer if you truly are a
sledgehammer do what you were made to do
tear down this house of cards
and build us something new
[Music]
War depending on what games you play
it's either changed irrevocably or it
never changes at all myself I like to
think it's a little bit of both there
are moments of drastic Evolution and
then for what seems like I hate that
[__] drill I wish it was shut up
sure he is
I don't know because I do like it like
this I'm sure he is
sure he is
all right
I'm sure he is I'm sure he is
some folks adapt to change others like
our poor friend Doug there are terrified
by it myself I'm not against tradition I
like the Comforts of A Familiar Taste as
much as anyone but when it comes to war
I hate that [__] drill